- My daughter, my youngest
daughter, loves doing makeup.
Do your daughters love doing makeup?
- My oldest daughter is a bit of an artist
and she likes doing more fantasy makeup.
So right now she's into TikTok.
(audience laughs)
- Oh my God that's so cool!
- And she likes doing graphic design,
and so this is her doing graphic
design makeup on herself,
but she also likes to do,
it looks kind of like anime-ish,
clownish, with like,
she puts freckles on herself,
and like orange blush.
- I love that.
- It's fine. (audience laughs)
- I walked in the other day,
my daughter was getting ready
like for school or whatever,
and I swear she got
into some kind of makeup
I didn't know she had,
and she looked like Mimi
from the Drew Carey Show.
(audience laughs)
- I love Mimi! (laughs)
- I was like, I was like--
- That is a strong choice.
- It's a good solid reference of like,
it's what she looked like.
And I was like,
"You look so beautiful."
I was like, "It's great!"
- I have no problem telling my child
that she's not allowed to leave
the house looking like that.
- I have no problem either.
- When she does the whole...
- But it's kind of fun
because it brings out the artist in them,
it's cool.
- Yeah, and I think
it's fine for her to play, and explore.
- So you've described them actually,
that they have bleeding
hearts, your children.
- They do, they're the opposite of me.
(Kelly and the audience laugh)
No, I mean I started working
when I was very young,
and my dad, I think he wanted a boy,
and so while he grew,
you know he raised me,
he's a feminist, my father,
he always said women deserve
equal parts in the world,
- I love your dad!
- in society,
and everything an much as men.
(audience cheers)
And so he always encouraged me to step up,
but especially in sports, even
though I was a sickly kid,
he was like, "You're not gonna throw,"
you know, he would say, "Not
gonna throw like a girl."
Which at the time, you know,
now I'm like,
"Well, a little bit weird
for you to say that."
But you know, at the
time he was just saying
I want you to be at the top level
of whoever it is you're doing sports with.
So, yeah,
- I love your dad!
- I kind of have
this more kind of like rough exterior.
I have a more, you know,
you don't show your emotions,
you just kind of keep it all in.
And it's like--
- Oh gosh,
I could never be Latino.
- It's a Catholic thing.
(audience laughs)
Yeah, and some of it's more like,
you know, you don't tell
people your business,
and if you have a problem,
talk to the priest!
(Kelly and the audience laugh)
- We are so opposite!
- Yeah I know, that was how I was sort of,
you know, grew up.
- I'm like TMI, I give way too much away.
- Yeah, yeah.
- Maybe we should hang out.
You could use a little more of this
and I could use a little more of that.
- We could do a mix.
- But you said your kids
are actually the opposite?
- So my kids came out
and everything is like,
"Ugh!" (audience laughs)
- They're me.
- Everything is like,
"Oh Gosh!"
- It's drama.
- [Jessica] And I'm like, "What happened?"
And it's like, "My shoelace broke."
And I'm like, "What? Your shoelace?
"Get another shoelace!"
It's like, what is going on?
Anyway, so they--
- They're dramatic.
- They're very dramatic.
But it's nice for me
because then it forces
me to open my heart,
and to have compassion
and empathy for people who
are operating in the world
very differently to me.
- Yeah, like me.
(audience laughs)
- Exactly like you!
I basically gave birth to you.
- You basically did.
It's full on karma happening
at my house though,
my kids are identical to me,
and I'm like, "Get over it!"
(audience laughs)
I'm so dramatic.
But I love,
you posted recently, it was
a pretty great mommy moment.
- Which one? (audience laughs)
- It might involve your son.
- Oh!
And it might involve poo.
- Poo.
Poo.
Yeah, in the bathtub.
- I mean let's talk about it.
- I just, it was so gross.
- Does it happen often?
(audience laughs)
- I think when he just
gets real comfortable.
So I know if there's like,
more than 10 minutes in the bathtub,
it's happening.
He just like gets--
- Look at her!
Your daughters have zero time,
- They have no time.
- They have zero time for this.
Oh my God I don't know what I'd do,
I think I'd laugh so
hard I would pee my pants
if my son did that. (audience laughs)
I think I might applaud it.
- So, what I said to the girls was like,
"Not only did you poo
on me, and barf on me
"several times throughout your babyhood."
'cause my kids get sick, motion sickness,
so every car ride, every train ride.
- Oh my God, that's horrible.
- Every plane ride,
every single one, it's coming out.
And so I was like,
and whilst in the bathtub with me.
- Oh no.
- That's fun, too.
So I'm like, "You guys need
to help me clean this up."
And they were like, "Gross, Mom!"
And so I made them.
- I love the eye roll, from the eldest.
That's my favorite, that was my favorite.
- She was like, "Ugh!"
- When you started your company
it was a very different world than kind of
what we're talking about in
our social climate right now.
Like for a woman to be heading
a billion dollar industry is kind of hard.
I mean, what are the challenges of that?
- Well,
gosh.
I mean, even eight to ten years ago,
raising money for a new business
was really, really hard for a woman.
And you know, even though
women start businesses
three times more than men,
even now less than two
percent get funding,
by the venture capital
to start their companies.
And so there's just a huge
inequality in all of it.
And certainly in corporate
America, and government,
you know, it's like a really,
even though we're half the
population we aren't really seen,
and we're not really treated equally.
- Or feel represented.
- And we don't feel
represented, because we aren't.
Yet we have spending power, ladies!
Ladies, we control the pocketbook!
(audience applauds)
And so, once I just,
once I really just kind of tapped in to
if I was gonna dream and create something,
I mean, it was crazy that I thought
that I could even become
successful as an actress.
I come from a very, you
know, modest background,
in the suburbs of L.A.,
and I was this kid with this
dream, and I figured it out.
I guess I had this fearlessness
and this dream that I
could create this company
that represents
women,
that stands for human health,
that has high standards
and transparency around how we operate.
And can be a global brand.
- And you care.
But that's the thing about your products,
you care.
- I do care. I really do.